Hey, I'm not interested in needle
fights, I came here for one reason, huh, it's
only for the season, so I
'm going home.
You'll be my right-hand man in
my flock.  There's also a personable Karashin, no aname, who doesn't want to be an idiot,
but
forcibly
started the ranks, Kudo
.
I entered the village of
Shikoku because my sister didn't want to leave, so I didn't
know that I or the Wolf Society would be friends.
Hey,
what are you
doing?  Hey,
ano
[music]
Tom I want to do something to everyone about the abnormal values ​​that come even with a little older sister
Hatchyuuta It's good from the beginning Because of the
heavy rain,
men and women are absolutely geeky The ninja world
is the top one
Even if  That's what parents and siblings do Shiba
Nai shanana
[music]
Seika Matsuzuki What will the boss do